je suis évidemment je concerné de
manière générale par le fait que au fil
des années la liberté soit réduite mais
je pense que la crise que nous
traversons actuellement ne se
caractérise pas par un déni des libertés
ce qui nous prive de notre liberté
actuellement c'est la circulation du
virus de la même façon que ce qui prive
l'économie de sa prospérité
ce ne sont pas les mesures sanitaires
mais c'est la circulation du virus et
les études les plus libérales le montre
aujourd'hui en chine
vous avez eu + 5 % de croissance au
japon vous avez plus 5% de croissance
encore est + 2 % en france nous sommes à
un an 10%
pourquoi parce que chez nous la crise
sanitaire dure toujours dans les pays
d'asie la crise sanitaire est sous
contrôle
depuis longtemps elle a été sous
contrôle très vite parce que des mesures
rapides ont été prises des mesures
fortes et immédiates
ensuite ces mesures ont pu être allégé
la population a pu retrouver une vie
quasi normale
moyennant le respect de règles
sanitaires de base qui sont très
communément intégrait en asie les
asiatiques aujourd'hui vivent en réalité
avec beaucoup plus de liberté que nous
cette liberté ils l'ont obtenu parce que
c'est une liberté puissance liberté de
capacité ils se sont mis en capacité
collectivement au nom du bien commun de
lutter contre le virus
nous nous avons fait le choix de laisser
les pics épidémiques prospérer et de ne
prendre des mesures comme au mans ces
pics épidémiques le résultat des courses
c'est que nous avons un niveau moyen de
circulation du virus qui est
perpétuellement aux essais ce niveau
moyen de circulation du virus
extrêmement roux qui nous prive de
liberté qui détruit notre vie sociale et
qui détruit notre vie économique
donc je pense que nous sommes victimes
d'une illusion d'optique nous pensons
que lutter contre les mesures sanitaires
nous rend notre liberté
je pense que c'est exactement l'inversé
nous sommes prisonniers d'une conception
typiquement libérale qui veut que la
liberté soit un droit
nous avons l'impression d'être privé
d'un droit à la liberté ce n'est pas un
droit c'est une capacité une capacité de
lutter et de résister mais je pense que
c'est une liberté que nous avons perdu
[Musique]